your family they're not in show business
like mine my family not in show business
they know nothing about show business
your family the same thing right nothing
about show business they were very
confused when you know all of us I was
like I want to be an actor I'm a
theatrical girl and my grandmother has
been very very supportive of it and
they've had the benefits of meeting my
co-stars oh do they get starstruck
around other celebrities oh my god yes
I took my grandma my very first big job
was working with Al Pacino and Salome
yeah and she took a picture with him and
they took it and they she framed it and
put it next to her bed so it was like on
a bedside table like Al Pacino a picture
of Al Pacino on your bedside that just
seems kind of I wouldn't him looking at
me what era Al Pacino is it Scarface Al
Pacino it was about six years ago okay
that's still like oh that's why yeah I
thought that was the biggest goal of her
life you know that picture of Al Pacino
there is one man who has surpassed Al
Pacino my grandmother's eyes and that is
Matthew McConaughey
oh yeah well he's such a charmer I bet
she went nuts he flirted with her like I
have never seen they they met at a
screening of interstellar and my grandma
was so starstruck and she kept saying I
want a selfie Matthew she then proceeded
to do a photo shoot in front of everyone
she's like you stand there I mean she
just started taking pictures of Matthew
I'm impressed she does selfies a
grandmother that does so yes except she
wasn't in the selfie I took a picture of
the two of them yeah and my god I don't
even think she realized I was taking the
picture she was just I think you have it
yeah we have it let's take a look at
this this is oh man
look at the way she's she's looking in
like she's just watching you know like
the universe be born you know even our
hand is a little awkward it's like this
yeah
you